mitchell is with us in chattanooga hi
mitchell welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey john hey dave um quick question i'm
in the tail end of baby step two
and i have a car lease or a fleece as
you would put it and
the turn in is in june
so i'm wondering if i should pause where
i'm at on the baby steps
i have obviously baby step one done but
should i pause baby step two
to stack cash toward buying a new or a
vehicle after i turn it in and cover any
expenses that i would have
at the end of that fleece yes buy a 2000
or 3 000
cars have them try to sell me this thing
yeah finance yes okay you're
right on that's a really brilliant idea
you've properly looked into the future
and avoided an emergency that really
shouldn't have been an emergency because
you thought about it six months ahead of
time five months ahead of time
you're going to be able to do this well
done yes that's exactly what you should
do
right now thank you thank you sir there
is a principle there
that christmas should not be an
emergency
they don't move it right it doesn't
surprise anybody this lease is coming up
that you know you're in the fall you're
going to go to school
these are not new pieces of information
and so you know develop some kind of a
game plan
and that's what he was doing shuffling
you know hi moving the shell around
hiding the p till
we find a game plan to figure this out
so i don't know i'm gonna get a car i
can't be walking i can't turn this thing
in i don't want to finance this thing
i don't want to keep it it needs to go
away and how am i gonna do that i can't
say
oh so i'm gonna stop beautifully done
good critical thinking
but people don't look out past freaking
friday i was gonna say i i
i have not read a book on it i could
probably call a buddy of mine that's got
some theory on it dave but you've done
this for a long time what
what is this where there is no vision
the people perish
when you don't look out past friday
everything yeah yeah
it's the car lease it's christmas it's
you're gonna die have a will it's that
your kid's gonna go to some sort of
secondary education i mean
it's everything one definition of
maturity though is just the ability to
delay pleasure the ability to look into
the future and go
i this should not be a surprise the
tires wearing out on your car
are a hundred percent probability that's
going to occur an oil change coming up
is
for sure gonna have a hundred percent
probability
and so you shouldn't need oh the tires
suddenly went out on my car
i mean you wouldn't believe the number
of times i had somebody that the tires
suddenly went out on their car so they
traded
ha ha ha cars